brought to you by the PlayStation
original series powers watch the series
premiere for free on March 10th at
playstation com it has been a big week
with a bunch of different stories coming
out of je-vc but I've got five of the
biggest so here's not mad at the most
sony had a big oops this week when it
accidentally permanently deleted its
list of winners from its ps4 anniversary
edition contest Sony Japan did have a
list of 123 winners who were supposed to
receive an extremely limited 20th
anniversary ps4 each of which there are
only twelve thousand three hundred
worldwide Japanese customers who bought
a ps3 ps4 Vita all PlayStation TV
between december and january of this
year were eligible to receive a calendar
that came with a code which could then
be submitted to sony to enter the
competition well now those are all gone
and Sony is asking those customers to
resubmit their code the question of how
a massive company accidentally
permanently deletes that information is
big you to speculate
virtual reality has been a big buzz
topic this week thanks to GDC and vows
offerings has been particularly popular
valve and HTC's vibe may look like a
gigantic block of cheese but it has 1200
x 1800 nixle screams / high and refresh
rates of 90 frames per second HTC have
claimed that this will eliminate the
jitter common in other VR headsets and
valves day this will abolish the issue
of motion sickness but also worth in
collaboration with steam VR base
stations that can detect movement
through an environment and a new room
tracking system called lighthouse this
week in cheap stuff here's a bunch of
PlayStation games that you can get for
free this month if you've got yourself a
plus subscription those of you with a
ps4 can get CounterSpy oddworld new and
tasty only going to and the wonderful
valiant hearts on ps3 you can get
counterspy papii oh and Sherlock Holmes
crimes and punishment while invita you
can grab CounterSpy once again and olly
olly to FX boxes more your style
Microsoft have announced a bunch of
cheap games via
deals with gold program including
Assassin's Creed unity for Xbox one and
Max Payne grey and red dead redemption
for 360 nvidia announced their shield
console this week and give what you can
expect from the Android device the
console which is powered by Nvidia's
Tegra x1 superchip is going to come
bundled with a shield controller and
will retail for 200 bucks thousand six
times more RAM and twice the processing
power of the xbox 360 it plays all media
available on the Google Play Store which
will include 50 android games at launch
nvidia shield will work with Nvidia's
grid subscription service which enabled
instant streaming of tripoli games at
720p or 1080p if you upgrade to grid
plus it also allows you to stream games
from your pc to the console like current
shield handheld devices do finally the
release date for Metal Gear Solid 5 the
phantom pain was revealed this week the
phantom pain will come to consoles on
sep tember one of this year and two pc
on sep tember 15 although the release
date itself leaked early konami did get
to announce the day one and collector's
editions of the game which include all
sorts of DLC weapons and collectibles as
well as physical loot including a map
and a half-scale replica of snakes
bionic arm which is definitely within
your mantelpiece
been missing let me know of you
particularly impressed by any of the
announcements from GBC this week and why
or why not this week on site I give you
a list of the most powerful protagonist
in gaming on the chest in two minutes
does some crime solving and seven can
show you how to be a superhero in Skyrim
those are all the things that I wanted
to tell you about this week we should
let me know what matter to you and I'll
catch you again on Monday